at the end of March I reported to you
that Donald Trump decided to fire the
head of the VA the Veterans Affairs
Department and to a point that doctor
guy who said Trump really is 6-3 and
weighs 239 pounds and could live to 200
years of age if he just ate a little bit
better and did a bit of exercise and it
was abundantly obvious at the time that
dr. Ronnie Jackson wasn't vetted he had
no real thought was given to the idea of
making Ronnie Jackson VA secretary other
than Trump loves people who Brown knows
him and that's what Ronnie Jackson did
so what the hell have him run the VA
despite having no real management
experience of large organizations
whatsoever which is sort of the key
thing that a VA secretary needs to do
and it took almost a full month but it
has now completely blown up in Trump's
face kind of for the wrong reasons I
would argue although it's still a good
thing in the end
and even though Ronnie Jackson is saying
he's not withdrawing his name from
consideration his nomination does appear
to be pretty doomed at this point he was
going to testify today in front of a
Senate committee but it got delayed
because of allegations that include that
Jackson was drunk while working he's
accused of creating a hostile work
environment which sounds potentially
like various kinds of either sexual
harassment physical abuse verbal abuse
who knows what that even means he was
improperly prescribing drugs to staff
while he was White House doctor and
that's according to a senator Jon Tester
and the way we learned about these
allegations is because people who worked
with Jackson felt they had to come
forward and they made these disclosures
and Jackson is insisting he's not
withdrawing his name from consideration
but Trump has basically torpedoed the
nomination saying that Jackson himself
might want to make the decision to drop
out these are quote ugly allegations he
doesn't want Jackson to go through
what's going to be an ugly process and
that if he were dr. Ronnie Jackson he
would bail so more than likely Jackson
is going to end up not being the
Secretary of the VA which is good but I
want to go back to the sort of original
lack of qualification for the job
Ronni Jackson is completely unqualified
to be secretary of the VA because he has
no experience running organizations he
has almost no management experience to
speak of he has no business running this
department the fact that he might have
prescribed some sleeping pills to
staffers when he was traveling with I
think it was Barack Obama at the time
that he was working for drinking on the
job yes it's bad I'm not defending any
of these things but he has no business
even being nominated on the basis of his
experience and it's on Trump right White
House a doctor isn't a position that you
need to be confirmed by the Senate for
and Trump has said again and again he's
going to hire the best people and yet
the so-called best people keep on
resigning being forced to resign getting
fired getting caught in horribly
embarrassing situations and nomination
after nomination has failed because
Trump keeps putting these unqualified
people in front of in front of the
Senate so I'm not saying I don't care
about the White House doctor being drunk
I'm not saying I don't care about the
White House doctor prescribing
medications inappropriately for people
but this is a broader problem which is
that it's the exact type of swamp
filling cronyism that supposedly we
weren't gonna see under Donald Trump
yeah but I think that if it was just
about being unqualified Jackson still
would have skated through this any more
confirmation process because this is the
VA secretary certainly an important
position but you usually just let the
president choose whomever he wants yes
that I think it's because of the
scandals it's because of the
over-prescription showing up drunk he's
the problem I don't doubt for a second
that the real reason that this guy
shouldn't be VA secretary was not going
to keep him from being VA secretary
which is why I'm still glad that this
happened but this is the epitome of the
Trump administration or sort of
microcosm in any case right it's a
nomination that has cronyism not hiring
the best people lack of professionalism
promotion of people who just placate the
president and the general feeling that
Trump and the people he's appointing are
all in way over their heads and the lack
of vetting is a small piece of it it's
the bigger picture that's concerning and
I want to remind you of something else
the VA had supposedly been mangled by
Obama
major disrespect to our veterans of the
military Trump ran on the military will
be a top priority respective veterans
will be a top priority
getting the VA turned around is going to
be a top priority isn't it hugely
disrespectful to the veterans that Trump
claims Obama didn't respect and
Democrats don't respect that he would
hire such an unqualified person and
that's the broader concern that I have
here and whatever the reason it seems as
though this is a nomination that is
doomed and we should all be glad for
that even if it's over what which would
actually be the least concerning
elements of Broni jackson's past send me
your thoughts about this you can discuss
it on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash read it we'll take a quick break
the conclusion to my interview with
Stephen bonell comes up next this
episode of the show is made possible in
part by zipper that's ZPE
our zipper is designing a global
decentralized peer-to-peer alliance
through which companies can provide
secure global and diversified investment
portfolios to minimize risk zippers
initial coin offering for their new
cryptocurrency starts April 16th zippers
goal is to use smart contract technology
to provide a revolutionary method of
funding transactions between borrowers
and lenders worldwide and one of the
best potential benefits would be zippers
ability to allow people with no credit
to borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
the zipper blockchain if you're watching
this on youtube look in the description
for a link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty program this is not financial
advice and of course everyone should do
their own research before spending money
anywhere